all right doctor
um and then just for the record if I
could just get your first last name and
your title
this is Dr William Schaffner
s-c-h-a double f as in Frank n e r I'm a
professor of infectious diseases at the
Vanderbilt University Medical Center in
Nashville Tennessee Music City USA
all right Dr shaffner thank you so much
for talking to us we appreciate your
time and just to kind of uh jump right
into it um we're hearing this word
triple demic here
um what should we be I mean should we be
worried about this and exactly what is
it
well the triple demek is referring to
the fact that at the moment there are
three major winter respiratory viruses
out there that are very active of course
number one is covid that's been sailing
along hasn't really upticked yet but the
other two viruses have come very very
early for example let's start with
influenza influenza came four to six
weeks early and began to infect people
in a very vigorous way certainly in my
neck of the woods we're seeing a lot of
flu not only in children but adults and
it's sending many of those persons to
the hospital
the third virus is one that is
abbreviated
RSV most people haven't heard about it
its fancy name is respiratory
Sensational virus long thought to be
exclusively a virus that affects
children particularly very young
children we now know that RSV also can
affect older persons particularly those
who have underlying lung disease and
heart disease it too is a virus that
usually is out there in January or
February but hello October November now
December this virus has also come early
and is infecting many children and quite
a few adults also so we have a triple
demek covet influenza RSV all pretty
much at the same time wow
yeah it's definitely alarming here
because you definitely need to be
prepared to make sure that you don't
catch anything especially with the
winter uh months and just the colder
season everyone is you know just kind of
inside here but talking here
um for our state of Nevada we're seeing
this thing called the superbug
um and it's really kind of uh we're
seeing just a an uptick here in cases
almost uh 800 cases 63 deaths here
um what should people know about this
well this superbug is called Canada orus
it's a fungus
that belongs to a family of fungi that's
usually pretty benign this is a fungus
that many of us have in our bodies and
we never notice it or it can cause in
some people a an inflammation of the
esophagus you know the the the feeding
tube and back in the throat and
occasionally it can cause in women a
vaginal uh infection so usually pretty
benign but this variant which has
cropped up in several parts of the world
is more ferocious it generally hovers
around hospitals infecting people who
are otherwise already very ill and
receiving antibiotics
it can be out in the environment and it
when it infects these people it can get
into their bloodstream and cause other
infections in organ systems and to make
the challenge even greater it's often
somewhat difficult to treat because it
can be resistant to some of the
anti-fungal drugs that we usually use so
it's challenging and it's cropped up
here in the United States starting in
2016 in hospitals Here There and
Everywhere
but there is treatment we should mention
that right
there is treatment we have other
anti-fungal agents and when patients are
infected they are put in their private
rooms in isolation and healthcare
workers wear gowns and gloves caring for
them so they won't spread it to others
and there's a lot of intensive
disinfection of the inanimate
environment around them so a lot of good
infection control usually coordinated
with the local public health department
all right good information there for for
our viewers all right so jumping back a
little bit
um I want to go back to covid um talking
about the boosters right now so many
people are kind of like on on the fence
as to whether they get the shot or not
um who should be getting them and why
I'd like everybody to jump off the fence
join many of us who've already been
boosted it's now recommended for
everyone get this starting at age five
it's an updated vaccine we've taken the
original covet vaccine updated it now we
call it bivalent because we have a new
component in it that's more effective
against these new covet strains those
Omicron strains that are out there you
know we've updated it in a way similar
to The Way We update the influenza
vaccine each year and in order to get
the best protection over the next winter
months against covid particularly
against serious covet the kind that will
put you in the hospital it's recommended
that you receive the booster uh ask your
health care provider have a conversation
with them I hope and I would anticipate
they would encourage you to get
vaccinated certainly everyone who works
on my medical center we're all boosted
it's always great to have that
conversation going with your doctor if
you have any questions of course because
there's so many individual cases
obviously different needs there
um talking going back to um RSV uh as
we're seeing that the cases are going up
you mentioned earlier a little bit about
the topic but what should parents what
what do you think parents need to know
before they go to the ER
well think about this
this is a virus that when it first
infects you is usually the most severe
you can get repeated infections
throughout the years for the most part
it produces the symptoms of a bad common
cold but particularly in very young
children children uh under a couple of
years of age it can get down into their
bronchial tubes cause inflammation those
mucous membranes swell and that causes
difficulty breathing
if your young child at this time of the
year or any time of the year really has
stopped eating is not taking fluids
looks poorly and particularly if they
have any difficulty breathing
please take them to a health care
provider very very quickly they can be
taken care of
pediatricians know how to help children
through this infection and almost all of
them come out on the other side
perfectly fine
and Doctor also um Health officials here
today they're they uh they made an
announcement here that we have a code
red for hospital beds basically just
over capacity here uh in Nevada uh which
what what does this all mean here for
residents moving forward
well what's happening across the country
not only in Nevada is that these three
viruses are really straining Health Care
Systems
around here we have lots of infection
and we're working very hard but we
haven't been overwhelmed yet it does
mean that Health Systems have to provide
longer coverage more people out there
people are working longer and they may
have to adjust actually the sorts of
patients that are admitted to hospitals
for a while for example people who are
scheduled for elective procedures they
find that they have to postpone those
because we need those beds for people
who are acutely ill
and then one last question doctor Before
I Let You Go
um you know just overall just the
primary way here to stay safe
um but get your vaccines I mean are you
also recommending maybe just kind of
bring that mask back up especially
during um the holidays when people are
starting to gather here to celebrate
well Christian I'm so glad you asked
because there are some things we can do
to protect ourselves our families and
our communities
fundamental is getting vaccinated and
I'm talking about two vaccines the covet
booster everyone five and older is
eligible for that and the regular
seasonal influenza vaccine everyone's
six months of age and older is
recommended to receive that both of
those vaccines can help prevent the
serious complications of those
infections and I recognize we're asking
people to roll up both their sleeves
coveted and flu but it's very important
number two good hand hygiene that RSV
can get on your fingers then if you
touch your nose or your mouth you can
infect yourself so frequent hand hygiene
if you do become ill
contact your health care provider I
didn't say go because you don't want to
spread it to everyone in the waiting
room but contact them because we have
treatments particularly for covid and
for influenza that can ameliorate the
severity of those infections
and particularly for people at high risk
of the complications of both these
viruses older people people who are have
have underlying illnesses heart disease
lung disease diabetes people who are
immune compromised dust off that mask
put it back on when you go out into
crowds and that includes the mall if
you're going shopping
social distancing may be a good idea I
know you'd like to go to all those
parties but if you really have an
underlying illness
think about it twice maybe it's time to
stream a movie rather than rent a movie
yeah it's also a very good time to maybe
show off that holiday spirit with the
mass you can always obviously just
decorate it there but you could give a
reminder here for viewers is there a
risk of getting the covet booster shot
and the flu at the same time or do you
recommend just kind of getting them uh
in different dates you can actually get
them both at the same time no harm
except yes both arms may be sore for a
day or two but other than that there's
no contraindication to getting them both
at the same time
if you want to spread them out please
make an early New Year's resolution to
absolutely get that second dose because
you know a vaccine deferred is often
unfortunately a vaccine that was never
received so uh
uh you know a bird in the hand is worth
two in the bush so get them at the same
time
all right thank you so much Dr shaffner
thank you so much for your time we
appreciated anything else that you want
to uh add that I forgot to ask we're
comprehensive here Christian thank you
thank you so much I appreciate it